This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A quick heads up. This episode has some offensive language. After Minneapolis police officer Derek Chauvin murdered George Floyd last year, tens of thousands of people all over the world took to the streets to protest police violence against black people. to protest police violence against black people. BOOSLESS MADDER! BOOSLESS MADDER! And if you look at images from these marches, you'll probably start to notice a common color scheme. Lots of red, black, and green. 99 PI producer, Christopher Johnson.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。先提醒一下，本期节目包含一些冒犯性语言。去年，明尼阿波利斯警官德里克·肖文谋杀乔治·弗洛伊德后，全球数万人走上街头，抗议针对黑人的警察暴力。抗议针对黑人的警察暴力。黑人的命也是命！黑人的命也是命！如果你看看这些游行的照片，你可能会开始注意到一种常见的配色方案。大量的红色、黑色和绿色。《99%隐形》制作人，克里斯托弗·约翰逊。
You'll see those colors everywhere. Red, black and green, picket signs and banners. Red, black and green hoodies and hats. And red, black and green picket signs and banners, red-black and green hoodies and hats, and red-black and green flags. Sometimes it's good to see that red-black and green flag, particularly when there's times of strife and people outrage and angry, and they start to come to that realization
你会到处看到这些颜色。红色、黑色和绿色，抗议标语和横幅。红色、黑色和绿色的连帽衫和帽子。还有红色、黑色和绿色的抗议标语和横幅，红色、黑色和绿色的连帽衫和帽子，以及红色、黑色和绿色的旗帜。有时看到那面红黑绿旗帜是件好事，特别是在充满冲突、人们感到愤怒和不满的时候，他们开始意识到
that we're not getting anywhere with the begging. Moorimakamao has several of these flags in different sizes, including a huge one that he likes to fly outside of his house. He says that wherever they're protest or demonstrations against threats to Black life, the red-black and green will be there. When people are ready for more than what they've been getting and they're ready to, you know, challenge the system, then you'll see the red-black and green flags come out. And not just at demonstrations.
我们靠乞求是得不到任何结果的。莫里亚马·卡马乌有几面不同尺寸的这种旗帜，包括一面他喜欢在自家屋外悬挂的巨大旗帜。他说，无论哪里有针对威胁黑人生命行为的抗议或示威，红黑绿旗帜就会出现在那里。当人们准备好争取比以往更多的东西，准备好去挑战这个体制时，你就会看到红黑绿旗帜出现。而且不仅仅是在示威活动中。
This tricolor scheme has been used on t-shirts, on high-top chucks, and in works of art that have sold for millions of dollars. The flag was invented to unite black people all over the world who were living under racial repression. And when it first came into existence, the flag posts some bold questions about where black people owed their loyalty
这种三色方案已被用于T恤、高帮帆布鞋以及售价数百万美元的艺术品中。这面旗帜的发明是为了团结全世界生活在种族压迫下的黑人。当它最初出现时，这面旗帜提出了关于黑人应向何处效忠的大胆问题
to the nations where their lives were demeaned and threatened, or to a new nation one they'd built entirely for themselves. And for hundreds of thousands of Black folks, the red-black and green symbolized the answer. The flag has been in use since 1918, but I'm going to start a couple decades before that, with the story of a super racist song about flags. In the beginning of the 20th century, there was Vordival, there was Minster C, in America, and there was the tradition of Kuhn songs. Can I say that word Christopher? This is writer and historian Colin Grant.
是效忠于那些贬低和威胁他们生命的国家，还是效忠于一个他们完全为自己建立的新国家。对于成千上万的黑人来说，红色、黑色和绿色象征着答案。这面旗帜自1918年以来一直在使用，但我打算从几十年前讲起，讲一个关于旗帜的超级种族主义歌曲的故事。在20世纪初，有杂耍表演，有吟游诗人，在美国，还有“黑人歌曲”的传统。克里斯托弗，我能说那个词吗？这是作家兼历史学家科林·格兰特。
He's talking about an old style of American music that's named after a racial slur. Coon songs were exactly what they sound like. The lyrics were deeply racist based on gross stereotypes about Black life and speech patterns, usually sung over a ragtime piano. And in 1900, one of the biggest songs of the genre came out. There was a very famous coon song called Every Race has a flag but the coon. And it was a song that lampooned black people for not having their own flag. And lampooned them for the idea that they should have their own flag.
他谈论的是一种以种族歧视用语命名的古老美国音乐风格。“黑人歌曲”正如其名。歌词极其种族主义，基于对黑人生活和言语模式的粗俗刻板印象，通常伴随着拉格泰姆钢琴曲演唱。1900年，该流派最著名的歌曲之一问世了。有一首非常著名的黑人歌曲叫《每个种族都有旗帜，除了黑人》。这首歌嘲讽黑人没有自己的旗帜。并嘲讽他们想要拥有自己旗帜的想法。
Two white composers wrote this song and I got invited to play the sheet music for me. Here's what it sounds like. In the lyrics, the head of a black social club gets up to speak. And he says he's just come back from a Labor Day parade where he saw all these different races proudly waving their national flags. Ireland has her harp and shamrock, England floats her lion-bowled, even China waves a dragon, Germany and Eagle Gold. And then he comes to the US. And what won't Yankees do for the old red, white and blue? The lyrics seem to drive at the idea that the stars and stripes didn't belong to black
两位白人作曲家写了这首歌，我让人为我演奏了乐谱。听起来是这样的。在歌词中，一个黑人社交俱乐部的负责人站起来发言。他说他刚从劳动节游行回来，在那里他看到所有这些不同的种族自豪地挥舞着他们的国旗。爱尔兰有她的竖琴和三叶草，英国飘扬着她的狮子旗，甚至中国也挥舞着龙旗，德国有金鹰旗。然后他提到了美国。扬基人为了那面红白蓝旗帜会做什么呢？歌词似乎旨在表达星条旗不属于黑人
people, that they'd need something else to represent them. The song went on to propose a flag for black people that's crammed with all these racist stereotypes. Every race has a flag, was performed by more than 100 touring Vodville acts and was part of the Vodville circuit for more than three decades. It was huge, which isn't surprising given the era. The U.S. wasn't even two generations out of slavery. Jim Crow and separate but equal were in full effect.
人们，他们需要别的东西来代表他们。这首歌接着为黑人提议了一面塞满了所有这些种族主义刻板印象的旗帜。《每个种族都有旗帜》由100多个巡回杂耍表演团体演出，并在杂耍巡回演出中存在了三十多年。它非常火爆，考虑到那个时代，这并不奇怪。美国距离奴隶制结束还不到两代人。吉姆·克劳法和“隔离但平等”政策全面生效。
Linching and other terrorist violence surged. Black Americans were getting the message from all sides, including popular music, that they weren't respected or safe or really even considered fully American. Now as gross as the song was, Deliric's hinted at something that did resonate for Black folks. That actually a flag was something that enabled people to be welded together. That idea was one which many black people understood. And in particular, a Jamaican-born labor organizer and journalist named Marcus Garvey.
私刑和其他恐怖暴力激增。美国黑人从四面八方，包括流行音乐中得到一个信息，那就是他们不受尊重、不安全，甚至根本不被视为完全的美国人。现在，尽管这首歌很恶心，但歌词暗示了一些确实引起黑人共鸣的东西。那就是旗帜确实是一种能让人们团结在一起的东西。这个想法是许多黑人所理解的。特别是，一位牙买加出生的劳工组织者和记者，名叫马库斯·加维。
In the early 1900s, Garvey bounced around Central and South America trying to start some advocacy newspapers fighting for working black people, but he wasn't having much luck. Garvey wanted more work opportunities and some adventure. He was also curious to see how black people like himself were living in other parts of the British Empire. So, in 1912, he set off across the Atlantic. Young Marcus Garvey in his mid-twenties, he went to England at that time for someone in the British colonies, London was where he would go to try to establish yourself to say,
20世纪初，加维在中美洲和南美洲辗转，试图创办一些为劳动黑人争取权益的宣传报纸，但他运气不佳。加维想要更多的工作机会和一些冒险。他也很好奇想看看像他这样的黑人在大英帝国的其他地方是如何生活的。于是，1912年，他横渡大西洋。年轻的马库斯·加维二十多岁时去了英国，当时对于英国殖民地的人来说，伦敦是他们试图立足的地方，去说，
I have arrived, I'm going to partake of this blended imperial enterprise which the British had ruled over for centuries, he's going to go to the heart of empire. In London, Garvey landed a gig in a newspaper that carried stories about Black life throughout the diaspora. He also got a pass to the British Museum, which had a large library. Garvey began reading ideas totally new to him, ideas that came to be known as Pan-Africanism is concerned with the unity and liberation of Africa and people of African heritage. I like to think of it as a mighty river with many streams and currents. Hakim Adi, a professor of African and Black to Aspera history, says, the source of that
“我来了，我要参与这个英国统治了几个世纪的混合帝国事业”，他要深入帝国的中心。在伦敦，加维在一家报纸找到了一份工作，该报纸刊登关于整个散居地黑人生活的故事。他还获得了一张大英博物馆的通行证，那里有一个大型图书馆。加维开始阅读对他来说全新的思想，这些思想后来被称为泛非主义，关注非洲和非洲裔人民的团结与解放。我喜欢把它想象成一条拥有许多支流和水流的强大河流。非洲和黑人散居史教授哈基姆·阿迪说，那条河流的源头是
river is the transatlantic slave trade. Slavery forced together millions of people from across the African continent. Adi believes pan-Africanism started there more than 400 years ago. It developed as those people with different languages and cultures began to understand their shared conditions and then align to change them. By the early 20th century, Black intellectuals had done a lot of thinking and writing about global Africa-centered black identity. Ideas about repatriation.
跨大西洋奴隶贸易。奴隶制迫使来自非洲大陆各地的数百万人聚集在一起。阿迪认为泛非主义在400多年前就在那里开始了。随着那些拥有不同语言和文化的人开始理解他们共同的处境，并联合起来改变它们，它便发展起来了。到了20世纪初，黑人知识分子对全球以非洲为中心的黑人身份进行了大量的思考和写作。关于遣返的思想。
Ideas about the importance of independent states like Haiti, like Ethiopia, like Liberia. Ideas about colonialism and what needed to be done to reform it. And ideas about the glories of historic African civilization. So it's in this sort of context that Garvey and his work develop. One big part of this development was the way Garvey thought about Africa. As a kid, he'd been taught that Africans were primitive and backwards with no history to speak of. What he'd read in London told him the opposite was true. Garvey realized that Africa could be the center of racial pride for all of black humanity.
关于海地、埃塞俄比亚、利比里亚等独立国家重要性的思想。关于殖民主义以及需要做些什么来改革它的思想。以及关于历史悠久的非洲文明荣耀的思想。所以，正是在这种背景下，加维和他的工作得以发展。这种发展的一个重要部分是加维对非洲的看法。小时候，他被教导说非洲人是原始和落后的，没有任何历史可言。他在伦敦读到的东西告诉他事实恰恰相反。加维意识到非洲可以成为全人类黑人种族自豪感的中心。
Along with this pan-African thought, Garvey was also heavily influenced by writings about black self-sufficiency. The call to build a black world that was economically, politically and culturally independent from white society. Garry combined these ideas with his newfound afrocentrism, and a political philosophy started to emerge. It had been just two years since Marcus Garvey had arrived in London. He'd left Jamaica hoping to find work and for a chance to see more of the world. But what he found in the heart of the British Empire, the seat of a massive colonial power, was the way he thought to free the entire black world.
除了这种泛非思想，加维还深受关于黑人自给自足著作的影响。呼吁建立一个在经济、政治和文化上独立于白人社会的黑人世界。加维将这些思想与他新发现的非洲中心主义结合起来，一种政治哲学开始出现。距离马库斯·加维抵达伦敦才仅仅两年。他离开牙买加时希望能找到工作，并有机会看看世界。但在大英帝国的中心，这个庞大殖民强权的所在地，他发现了他认为可以解放整个黑人世界的方法。
Garvey became convinced that black people in Africa and throughout the diaspora share a common identity. They also shared a responsibility to advance the race and to protect it. And the safest place for them was one built solely by black hands. The idea that you had to forge a nation of your own, that you couldn't trust the man to look after yourself, and when I say the man, I mean the imperial powers were not going to further the likes of something like Marcus Garvey, all the black people of whom they ruled. And Garvey recognized through reading that actually he could conjure an alternative to the reality in which he found himself he could change the narrative. Garvey sailed back to the Caribbean in 1914. Those were still several years before he'd make the red, black, and green flag that he intended
加维确信，非洲和整个散居地的黑人拥有共同的身份。他们也肩负着推动种族进步和保护种族的责任。而对他们来说最安全的地方，是由黑人亲手建立的地方。那种你必须锻造一个属于自己的国家，你不能指望白人来照顾你的想法，当我提到“白人”时，我的意思是帝国列强不会推动像马库斯·加维这样的人，也不会推动他们统治下的所有黑人。加维通过阅读认识到，实际上他可以创造一个他所处现实的替代方案，他可以改变叙事。加维于1914年航行回加勒比海。那是在他制作出他打算代表全人类黑人的红黑绿旗帜之前的几年。
to stand for all of black humanity. But he was already thinking about how to build the kind of nation that such a flag would represent. On the ship going back from England to Jamaica, he famously said to himself, where is the black man's army? Where is the Black man's army? Where is the Black man's military chief? He looked about in his sonum. All his son was subjugation and he said to himself, he was going to build the army and he was going to establish a new African empire. Garvey put his pan-African thinking to work almost as soon as he landed in Jamaica. He formed an organization called the UNIA, the Universal Negro Improvement Association.
但他已经在思考如何建立一个能代表这种旗帜的国家。在从英国回牙买加的船上，他对自己说了一句名言：“黑人的军队在哪里？黑人的军队在哪里？黑人的军事首领在哪里？”他环顾四周，看到的只有征服，他对自己说，他要建立这支军队，他要建立一个新的非洲帝国。加维一回到牙买加，就几乎立即将他的泛非主义思想付诸实践。他成立了一个名为UNIA的组织，即“世界黑人进步协会”。
Its primary objective was to establish a universal confertunity among the race. Here's how Garvey described the UNIA many years later. Hello citizens of Africa. I greet you in the name of the Universal Negro Bument Association, the novelization that seeks to unite into one solid body, the 400 million Negroes of the world. For the purpose of centering our industrial, commercial, educational, social and political conditions. But the UNIA got off to a so, so start. Garvey once again found himself strapped for cash. So to raise money and build a following, he left Jamaica again.
其主要目标是在种族之间建立普遍的共识。多年后，加维是这样描述UNIA的：“你好，非洲的公民们。我以世界黑人进步协会的名义向你们致意，这个旨在将全世界4亿黑人团结成一个坚实整体的组织。目的是集中我们的工业、商业、教育、社会和政治条件。”但UNIA的开局并不顺利。加维再次发现自己资金短缺。为了筹集资金并建立追随者，他再次离开了牙买加。
This time, he headed to Harlem. And that's where Marcus Garvey really took off as a race leader. America is the seat of wealth. It's a seat to promise, the seat of any person who has some ambition that wants to have a bigger canvas to realize his ambition. So he was a young man in his mid to late 20s, he came with a hope and a prayer,
这一次，他前往哈莱姆。在那里，马库斯·加维真正作为一名种族领袖崛起。美国是财富的所在地。它是希望的所在地，是任何有抱负、想要有更大舞台来实现抱负的人的所在地。所以他是一个二十多岁出头的年轻人，他带着希望和祈祷而来，
with not too far then to rub together. When Garvey arrived in 1916, Harlem was going through some major changes of its own. The black population there had been surging for about a dozen years. Folks were coming from other parts of New York City, from down south, and like Garvey, from the Caribbean. It was the beginning of the so-called New Negro era, or the Negro Renaissance. In art and politics, black Harlemites from throughout the diaspora argue furiously over what it meant to be black. Garvey jumped headlong into the debate.
身上没带多少钱。当加维1916年抵达时，哈莱姆本身正在经历一些重大变化。那里的黑人人口已经激增了大约十二年。人们从纽约市的其他地方、从南方，以及像加维一样，从加勒比海地区涌入。那是所谓的“新黑人”时代或“黑人文艺复兴”的开始。在艺术和政治领域，来自世界各地的黑人哈莱姆人激烈地争论着身为黑人意味着什么。加维一头扎进了这场辩论。
He'd stand on one of Harlem's famous soap boxes and address a crowd with his nascent pan-Africanist ideas. But not everybody was feeling young Marcus Garvey, including the era's most famous black intellectual. The premier man, the premier leader at that time was W.E.B. Du Bois. And his organization, the NAACP, had captured the imagination of black people. At the time, Du Bois was ascendant. W.E.B. Du Bois felt that full civil rights were the keys to black freedom in a country
他会站在哈莱姆著名的肥皂箱上，向人群发表他萌芽中的泛非主义思想。但并不是每个人都看好年轻的马库斯·加维，包括那个时代最著名的黑人知识分子。当时的首要人物、首要领袖是W.E.B.杜波依斯。他的组织，全国有色人种协进会（NAACP），已经俘获了黑人的想象力。当时，杜波依斯正处于上升期。W.E.B.杜波依斯认为，充分的公民权利是黑人在一个
that was hostile to their survival and peace. He believed in America as a viable nation for black folks. It would take real struggle, but there was a path for black people to be whole and safe under the stars and stripes. Marcus Garvey saw things totally differently. He came to believe that the fundamental problem for black people in the west was the west itself. There was no way the US or Great Britain or any other Western power was going to let black people be truly free. Garvey believed that black people were, as he put it, a mighty race, and that the only
对他们的生存与和平充满敌意的国家中获得自由的关键。他相信美国是一个适合黑人的可行国家。这需要真正的斗争，但黑人在星条旗下是有可能变得完整和安全的。马库斯·加维的看法完全不同。他开始认为，西方黑人的根本问题在于西方本身。美国、英国或任何其他西方大国绝不可能让黑人真正自由。加维相信黑人正如他所说的那样，是一个“强大的种族”，而唯一的
way for them to realize their full potential and to survive the anti-blackness of the West was to come together and build a separate black world. Africa with 400 million black people can do it. If you're gonna do it, I don't have them. What are the nations have done? What are the races that have done? The US that has died. The US. The more time Garvey spent in the US, the firmer that position became.
实现他们全部潜力并从西方的反黑人情绪中生存下来的方法，就是团结起来，建立一个独立的黑人世界。拥有4亿黑人的非洲可以做到。如果你要去做，我没有他们。其他国家做了什么？其他种族做了什么？美国已经死了。美国。加维在美国待的时间越长，这一立场就越坚定。
In the South, he'd witnessed firsthand the struggles of rural black America living under Jim Crow. He'd come from Jamaican society where class, often outweighed race privilege. like America living under Jim Crow. He'd come from Jamaican society, where class, often at Wade Raceprivilege, but in the US, he noticed that was flipped, a dynamic which inspired Garvey
在南方，他亲眼目睹了生活在吉姆·克劳法下的美国农村黑人的挣扎。他来自一个阶级往往重于种族特权的牙买加社会。但在美国，他注意到情况反过来了，这种动态激发了加维
to center his message on blackness. He believed that actually race should come before class, that you only became powerful by uniting together, by having a powerful voice through sheer numbers. Therefore, we should cleave together as black people and place a primacy on race." Then something happened that put the difference between Du Bois and Garvey in sharp relief, and gave Garvey an opportunity to really articulate the Pan-Africanist vision that he'd been developing since his days
将他的信息集中在黑人身份上。他认为实际上种族应该先于阶级，你只有通过团结一致，通过庞大的人数拥有强大的声音，才能变得强大。“因此，我们应该作为黑人紧密团结在一起，并将种族置于首位。”然后发生了一件事，使杜波依斯和加维之间的分歧变得鲜明，并给了加维一个机会，真正阐明他自在大英博物馆日子以来一直在发展的泛非主义愿景。
at the British Museum. America is called to our first volunteer as a kid, thousands of them, and millions more to follow. When Woodrow Wilson brought America into the First World War, under the idea that they were going to make the world safe for democracy, Garvey was stabbed on his soapbox and say, that's all very well, Woodrow Wilson, but how about making Georgia safer the Black man first? The US entered World War I in April 1917. That summer there was large-scale racial violence in several cities. Some of the worst was in East St. Louis.
美国被称为我们的第一个志愿者，成千上万的人，还有更多的人跟随。当伍德罗·威尔逊带着“让世界变得安全以实现民主”的理念将美国带入第一次世界大战时，加维站在他的肥皂箱上说：“这很好，伍德罗·威尔逊，但先让佐治亚州对黑人变得安全怎么样？”美国于1917年4月参加第一次世界大战。那年夏天，几个城市发生了大规模的种族暴力事件。最严重的一些发生在东圣路易斯。
A labor dispute turned into an all-out assault on the city's black residents. Whites set fire to black neighborhoods. Whites snipers shot and killed black people in the streets. There were mob beatings and lynchings. The suddenness and the sheer shock of the violence of East Simplyweak changed everybody, and yet Woodrow Wilson was going to take America into the war because America was this great savior without recognizing that many of the transgressions that were going to be challenged in Europe also existed on home soil. Sometimes, Garry would respond to racist violence with calls for revenge or arms self-defense.
一场劳资纠纷演变成了对该市黑人居民的全面攻击。白人放火烧毁了黑人社区。白人狙击手在街上射杀黑人。发生了暴徒殴打和私刑。东圣路易斯暴力的突然性和纯粹的冲击力改变了所有人，然而伍德罗·威尔逊却要将美国带入战争，因为美国是这个伟大的救世主，却没有认识到许多将在欧洲受到挑战的罪行也存在于本土。有时，加维会以呼吁复仇或武装自卫来回应种族暴力。
The boys in NAACP stood firmly against this approach. The two men also disagreed on whether or not black men should enlist to fight in Europe, given the racial climate in the US. So whereas the boys said we must forget our differences between ourselves as Black and the White men, we must put our shoulders to the wheel and fight the common enemy. Garver is saying the very opposite. Garver is saying, no, do not go off and fight the White man's war for him. Because come the end of the war, things will were overt to the way that they'd been before.
杜波依斯和NAACP坚决反对这种做法。两人还对考虑到美国的种族气候，黑人是否应该应征去欧洲作战存在分歧。所以，当杜波依斯说“我们必须忘记我们黑人和白人之间的分歧，我们必须肩并肩战斗，对抗共同的敌人”时，加维说的恰恰相反。加维说：“不，不要去为白人打仗。因为战争结束时，事情会恢复到以前的样子。”
And that's exactly what happened. As those so just came back and some of them were even lynched in their uniforms, there are many people who saw the Garvey had been right. The idea that World War I would make things better for black people didn't pan out. In fact, as the war ended, cities and towns across the US exploded in an unprecedented wave of anti-black violence. It had been 50 years since black Americans were declared full citizens of the US. Black people had invested in the democratic process, and now they'd gone overseas and fought and died under the stars and stripes. And yet the country's deadly racial caste system stayed firmly in place just as Marcus Garvey had predicted.
而这正是发生的事情。当那些士兵回来时，有些人甚至穿着制服被私刑处死，许多人看到加维是对的。第一次世界大战会让黑人生活变得更好的想法并没有实现。事实上，随着战争结束，美国各地的城市和城镇爆发了前所未有的反黑人暴力浪潮。距离美国黑人被宣布为美国完全公民已经50年了。黑人投资了民主进程，现在他们已经出国并在星条旗下战斗和牺牲。然而，正如马库斯·加维所预言的那样，这个国家致命的种族种姓制度依然稳固。
And I think that made him seem in the eyes of many black people a kind of prophet, a seer, someone who could see into the future, but also someone who was fearless. I mean, he was fearless. And that was very empowering. People wanted to align themselves with him, but they saw that he was a winner. Garvey had been adding up events in cities like East St. Louis. He saw what was happening to black soldiers and civilians alike.
我认为这使他在许多黑人眼中成为一种先知、预言家，一个能看穿未来的人，但也一个无所畏惧的人。我的意思是，他无所畏惧。这非常赋权。人们想与他结盟，因为他们看到他是一个赢家。加维一直在统计像东圣路易斯这样的城市的事件。他看到了黑人士兵和平民身上发生的事情。
If the question was to whom do black people owe their loyalty, Garvey's answer was clear. Black people owe their loyalty first to other black people. He recognized that in his mind, anyway, that black people were Africans in exile in America. And there was gonna be no place for them. There was no future for them in America. But Marcus Garvey had a plan.
如果问题是黑人应该效忠于谁，加维的答案很明确。黑人首先应该效忠于其他黑人。他认识到，至少在他看来，黑人是流亡在美国的非洲人。他们将没有立足之地。他们在美洲没有未来。但马库斯·加维有一个计划。
They had to get out, and they had to establish their own place, and that pace was going to be Africa. Garvey believed that every single black person on the planet was in Africa, and that the continent was their birthright. He said Africa should be free of colonial rule so that black people themselves can develop their own societies there. For 250 years we have struggled under the burden and rigged up slavery. We were maimed, we were brutalized, we were ravaged in every way. We are men, we have hope, we have passions, we have feelings, we have desires just like any other race.
他们必须离开，他们必须建立自己的地方，那个地方就是非洲。加维相信地球上的每一个黑人都在非洲，而这片大陆是他们的与生俱来的权利。他说非洲应该摆脱殖民统治，这样黑人自己就可以在那里发展自己的社会。“250年来，我们在奴隶制的重担和操纵下挣扎。我们被残害，被虐待，我们在各方面都被蹂躏。我们是人，我们有希望，我们有激情，我们有感情，我们有欲望，就像任何其他种族一样。”
And so Garvey would be calling for Africa for the Africans, those at home and those abroad. The cries raised all over the world of Canada, for the Canadians, of America, for the Americans, of England, for the English or France, for the French or Germany, for the Germans. Do you think it unreasonable to read a black-coloured world, for the cries of Africa for the Africans? Garvey had long understood that he needed cohesion in order to achieve his dream of an independent black world. The campaign for a homeland would fail if black people didn't see themselves as a single
所以加维会呼吁“非洲属于非洲人，无论是在国内还是在国外”。全世界都响起了“加拿大属于加拿大人，美国属于美国人，英国属于英国人，法国属于法国人，德国属于德国人”的呼声。你认为呼吁“非洲属于非洲人”建立一个黑人世界是不合理的吗？加维早就明白，为了实现他建立独立黑人世界的梦想，他需要凝聚力。如果黑人不能将自己视为一个单一的
global race. How are you going to cleave those people of that race together. What can you do to reimagine a society where whiteness is not the thing that defines you, you're not in opposition to whiteness, you are just black, you are just your own people. Ironically, part of the answer came from white people. Garvey drew on what he'd seen years earlier in London. He was inspired by how the British used symbols to flex their strength and to unite people across their vast empire.
全球种族，那么建立家园的运动就会失败。你如何将那个种族的那些人团结在一起？你能做些什么来重新构想一个社会，在那里白人身份不是定义你的东西，你不是在反对白人身份，你只是黑人，你只是你自己的人民。讽刺的是，部分答案来自白人。加维借鉴了他多年前在伦敦看到的东西。他受到英国人如何利用符号来展示力量并团结他们庞大帝国人民的启发。
He saw the great buildings of power. He saw this great columns with these admirals on top of them. He saw that the way that the British celebrated their history through symbols of conquest, it saw that the way that the British celebrated their history through symbols of conquest, through symbols of authority. I think he really understood the power of symbols to deliver people, to conjure this notion that you are part of something greater than yourself. Garvey had taken note of all the trappings of nationhood.
他看到了伟大的权力建筑。他看到了这些上面有海军上将的巨大圆柱。他看到了英国人通过征服的符号来庆祝他们的历史，他看到了英国人通过征服的符号、通过权威的符号来庆祝他们的历史。我认为他真正理解了符号的力量，可以解放人民，唤起这种你属于比你自己更伟大的东西的观念。加维注意到了所有国家地位的象征。
taken note of all the trappings of nationhood. He was very influenced by the idea that the show of power came through things like the idea of planting yourself under a flag of saying that you belong to a group. He recognized that's what Imperial powers did. Marcus Garvey filtered all of that inspiration through his black nationalist prism, and out came a flag, a banner that would stand for the entire black world. Garvey designed the Pan-African flag as a rectangle with three horizontal bars, red on top, then black, and green at the bottom.
注意到了所有国家地位的象征。他深受这种想法的影响，即权力的展示是通过诸如在旗帜下扎根、宣称你属于一个群体这样的事情来实现的。他认识到这就是帝国列强所做的。马库斯·加维通过他的黑人民族主义棱镜过滤了所有这些灵感，于是出现了一面旗帜，一面代表整个黑人世界的横幅。加维将泛非旗帜设计为一个矩形，带有三条水平条纹，顶部是红色，中间是黑色，底部是绿色。
According to the UNIA, the red stands for the blood spilled in the fight to protect and defend Africa. Green represents Africa itself. It's lushness and the motherland that Garvey I saw as their birthright, and black stands for the people of the continent and the diaspora. Garvey introduced the Pan-African banner in 1918 and it quickly became the symbol of
根据UNIA的说法，红色代表在保护和捍卫非洲的斗争中流下的鲜血。绿色代表非洲本身。它的郁郁葱葱和加维视为他们与生俱来权利的祖国，黑色代表非洲大陆和散居地的黑人。加维在1918年推出了泛非横幅，它很快成为了
his rapidly growing international movement. And that success came partly from the sheer potency of Garvey's message, which he spread throughout the Americas during these exhausting speaking tours. Plus, the UNIA's newspaper circulated Garveyism all over the world. And then, there was Garvey's single biggest recruiting tool. The UNIA's commercial and passenger steam ships called the Black Star Line. Garvey wanted to fleet it with sale between ports in North and South America, the Caribbean, and Africa.
他迅速发展的国际运动的象征。这种成功部分归功于加维信息的纯粹效力，他在这些令人筋疲力尽的巡回演讲中将这些信息传播到整个美洲。此外，UNIA的报纸在全世界传播了加维主义。然后，还有加维最大的招募工具。UNIA的商业和客运蒸汽船，被称为“黑星航运”。加维想要一支在北美和南美、加勒比海和非洲港口之间航行的船队。
The Black Star Line would be 100% Black-owned and operated. In a world where public transportation was often segregated and Black people were routinely limited to the lowest classes of travel, the Black Star Line promised comfort, respect, safety, and speed to its Black passengers. 5,000 Black folks showed up to watch the first Black Star line ship leave its East Harlem port in 1919. According to at least one observer, the crowd was delirious with excitement.
“黑星航运”将是100%由黑人拥有和运营的。在一个公共交通经常被隔离、黑人通常被限制在最低等级旅行的世界里，“黑星航运”承诺为其黑人乘客提供舒适、尊重、安全和速度。5000名黑人出现在1919年观看第一艘“黑星航运”船离开其东哈莱姆港口。据至少一位观察者称，人群因兴奋而神志不清。
The Black Star line never got as big as Garvey had envisioned, but it inspired pride and hope in Black people around the world. Brothers, this stuff is a dream, but you're better get time for it. There was even a song about the ships recorded while they were still active. Each and every one of those Black Star line vessels hosted the red, black and green colors from its masts. And when those ships came into harbor with the UNI flags flapping, there was the most extraordinary excitement because that was the
“黑星航运”从未达到加维所设想的规模，但它激发了世界各地黑人的自豪感和希望。兄弟们，这些东西是一个梦想，但你们最好有时间去实现它。甚至还有一首关于这些船的歌，是在它们还在运营时录制的。每一艘“黑星航运”船只的桅杆上都悬挂着红、黑、绿三色旗。当这些船只挂着UNIA旗帜驶入港口时，出现了最非凡的兴奋，因为那是
manifestation of something that they thought to be impossible. So the flags on board the ships acted to promote the growth and the huge ambition and reach of Marcus Garvey and the Universal Negra Improvement Association, but for the flags and the ships, there would be no mass movement. They needed those symbols in order for the movement to grow without those flags. There would be no Marcus Garvey in our memory.
他们认为不可能的事情的体现。所以船上的旗帜起到了促进马库斯·加维和世界黑人进步协会的巨大雄心和影响力的作用，但如果没有旗帜和船只，就不会有群众运动。他们需要这些符号才能使运动发展，没有这些旗帜，我们的记忆中就不会有马库斯·加维。
Garvey to me is the, I call him the standard bear of success under the rest who was blessed to do far more with less. Moria Makamau is the official historian of the UNIA. Make sure you also call him the outrunner in the outdoor, and out of this world. Third rock from the Sun, bar, and none, he far as I'm concerned. By the end of the decade, Garvey's movement was massive. Two million people had joined the UNIA.
对我来说，加维是逆境中成功的旗手，他有幸用更少的资源做了更多的事。莫里亚马·卡马乌是UNIA的官方历史学家。一定要称他为户外运动的先驱，而且是超凡脱俗的。在我看来，他是太阳系第三颗行星上最棒的，没有之一。到十年末，加维的运动规模巨大。两百万人加入了UNIA。
It would eventually become the largest organization in black history, and its members proudly flew the Pan-African banner. Yeah, you would see a lot of houses with,-black and green flags on the outside as well as mass meetings and local cities all around the globe. They would have red-black and green flags whenever they had meetings, red-black and green buttons as well on the lapel. And even some of the ministers would have their robes with red-black and green when they were preaching to the gospel, Garvey isn't. In 1920, the UNIA held its convention in New York City.
它最终成为黑人历史上最大的组织，其成员自豪地悬挂着泛非横幅。是的，你会看到很多房子外面挂着红黑绿旗帜，以及全球各地当地城市的大型集会。只要他们有会议，他们就会有红黑绿旗帜，翻领上也有红黑绿徽章。甚至一些牧师在传福音时，他们的长袍上也会有红黑绿的颜色。1920年，UNIA在纽约市举行了大会。
It was a sprawling month-long affair attended by tens of thousands of people. And there, the UNIA officially declared red, black, and green the colors of the Negro race. Then those colors were put on spectacular display. When the UNIA held a massive parade meant to conjure a state procession, the flag was part of this medley of symbols that Garvey used to project to the world, black unity, strength, and greatness.
这是一场为期一个月的盛大活动，有数万人参加。在那里，UNIA正式宣布红色、黑色和绿色为黑人种族的颜色。然后这些颜色被壮观地展示出来。当UNIA举行旨在唤起国家游行的大规模游行时，这面旗帜是加维用来向世界展示黑人团结、力量和伟大的符号组合的一部分。
Primarily, Marcus Garvey was a showman. And in 1920, Marcus Garvey put on the greatest show on earth and he had the uniform authority with his Victorian military regalia with his biconet helmet and his plumes in his helmet. There were huge choirs of a hundred and more on the streets walking with him. There were uniformed guards with their sabers rattling. There were black guards saying our time has come, downward lynching. There were bands playing. There was a spirit of carnival. It was the thing you wanted to be a part of and it was a
马库斯·加维主要是一位表演者。1920年，马库斯·加维上演了地球上最伟大的表演，他穿着维多利亚时代的军装，戴着双角帽，头盔上插着羽毛，展现了统一的权威。街上有成百上千人的大型合唱团与他同行。有穿着制服、佩剑叮当作响的卫兵。有黑人卫兵喊着“我们的时代到了，打倒私刑”。有乐队在演奏。有一种狂欢节的精神。这是你想参与的事情，它是
street performance that led to the most magnificent statement of black intent that they'd never been. But Marcus Garvey also drew a lot of fire. Federal investigators had been after Garvey since he first came to the U.S. And at the same time, W.E.B. Du Bois and other black leaders were also coming for Garvey. They said his talk of an African empire was foolish. They called his business dealing shady and said that they were especially dangerous to the working class black people who invested in them. Others saw the UNIAs pomp and military regalia as clownish
一场街头表演，导致了他们从未有过的最宏伟的黑人意图声明。但马库斯·加维也招致了很多攻击。联邦调查人员自加维第一次来到美国以来就一直盯着他。与此同时，W.E.B.杜波依斯和其他黑人领袖也在攻击加维。他们说他关于非洲帝国的谈话是愚蠢的。他们称他的商业交易是阴暗的，并说这对投资这些交易的工人阶级黑人尤其危险。其他人认为UNIA的排场和军事礼仪是滑稽的
and embarrassing to the race. A campaign called Garvey Must Go pressured law enforcement to redouble their investigation of the UNIA. Garvey was eventually locked up for almost three years for male fraud. In 1927, he was deported to Jamaica. UNIA shrank severely after that, especially in the United States. In 1940, Marcus Garvey died in London. He was 52 years old. Show me the race or the nation without a flag. Marcus Garvey once said in a speech, and I will show you a race of people without any pride. In the same address, Marcus Garvey invoked that minstrel tune from 1900.
并且让种族蒙羞。一场名为“加维必须走”的运动向执法部门施压，要求他们加倍调查UNIA。加维最终因邮件欺诈被关押了近三年。1927年，他被驱逐出境到牙买加。此后，UNIA严重萎缩，特别是在美国。1940年，马库斯·加维在伦敦去世。他享年52岁。“给我看看没有旗帜的种族或国家，”马库斯·加维曾在一次演讲中说，“我就会给你看一个没有任何自豪感的种族。”在同一次演讲中，马库斯·加维引用了那首1900年的吟游诗人曲调。
In song and mimicry they have said, every race has a flag but the Cune. But as far as Garvey was concerned, he'd silenced any notion of a flagless race, with the red black and green banner that was the red, the black and the green, around me, foreign in you, life, I tell, right, I'm hurt, we've got a piece of fucking the millions of the hype in the pile, that you will know. Yeah! It's been more than 80 years since Marcus Garvey passed, but the UNIA still exists, and members like Moriama Kamau still salute its century-old better. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
“在歌曲和模仿中，他们说，每个种族都有旗帜，除了黑人。”但就加维而言，他用红黑绿横幅平息了任何关于“无旗种族”的说法，那是红色、黑色和绿色，围绕着我，在你们之中，生命，我告诉，对，我受伤了，我们得到了数百万炒作的一块，你会知道的。耶！马库斯·加维去世已经80多年了，但UNIA仍然存在，像莫里亚马·卡马乌这样的成员仍然向其百年历史的旗帜致敬。哦耶，耶，耶。
You always keep the flag up in the house. Sometimes, you know, when I'm going to meet, I take the big flag on the train or hanging out my car when I'm riding down the street just so folks can actually, what's that? What country is this? But the red-blackened green has grown way beyond the UNIA. In the decades after Garvey's death, several African countries incorporated the Pan-African colors into their own national flags as they gained independence. In the U.S., the red-blackened green colors were prominent during the black power movement
你总是把旗帜挂在家里。有时，你知道，当我要去开会时，我把大旗带上火车，或者当我开车在街上行驶时把它挂在车外，只是为了让人们实际上问，“那是什么？这是什么国家？”但红黑绿已经远远超出了UNIA。在加维去世后的几十年里，几个非洲国家在获得独立时将泛非颜色纳入了他们自己的国旗中。在美国，红黑绿颜色在黑人权力运动中很突出
and the black consciousness Renaissance in the 1960s and 70s. Starting in the late 80s, the tricolors were a big part of hip-hop fashion. In a way, the Pan-African flag has done exactly what Garvey had hoped. He made this enduring symbol that transcends any one organization or country or even hemisphere. He created a single flag that's recognized all over the world as the symbol of blackness. Some of those like I said, the community who fly the flag, they know it makes them feel good. They may not understand its history, its full power, but they know it represents them as the people. Okay, so I want to say one last thing about the Pan African flag. I'm a black man.
以及20世纪60年代和70年代的黑人意识复兴。从80年代末开始，三色旗是嘻哈时尚的重要组成部分。在某种程度上，泛非旗帜完全实现了加维的希望。他制作了这个超越任何单一组织、国家甚至半球的持久符号。他创造了一面被全世界公认为黑人象征的单一旗帜。正如我所说，一些悬挂旗帜的社区，他们知道这让他们感觉良好。他们可能不了解它的历史、它的全部力量，但他们知道它代表了他们作为一个民族。好吧，所以我想关于泛非旗帜再说最后一件事。我是个黑人。
I was born in the US. As far back as I know, my family is from this country. They help build it. My mom worked for the DC government. My dad is a war vet, and so are a bunch of my uncles. My great-grandfather is buried at Arlington National Cemetery. But even with all this family history, for me, there's also the experience of being black in America, which can make safety and belonging feel
我出生在美国。据我所知，我的家人来自这个国家。他们帮助建立了它。我妈妈为华盛顿特区政府工作。我爸爸是退伍军人，我的很多叔叔也是。我的曾祖父被安葬在阿灵顿国家公墓。但即使有所有这些家庭历史，对我来说，还有作为美国黑人的经历，这会让安全感和归属感变得
tenuous. Standing under the stars and stripes is at best an uneasy and insecure thing, because the flag stands for lots of things, including imperialism and white supremacy. lots of things, including imperialism and white supremacy. So for me, it's not a place where I feel at home. Whenever I find myself in neighborhoods where US flags are displayed, unless it's a super black part of town, I get pretty uncomfortable. I don't feel safe. It's very different with the red, black, and green. If I see someone flying that flag outside of their home or in their business, I may have no idea what that person believes.
脆弱。站在星条旗下充其量是一件不安和不安全的事情，因为这面旗帜代表了很多东西，包括帝国主义和白人至上主义。很多东西，包括帝国主义和白人至上主义。所以对我来说，这不是一个让我感到宾至如归的地方。每当我发现自己身处悬挂美国国旗的社区时，除非是镇上非常黑人的地方，否则我会感到非常不舒服。我没有安全感。红黑绿旗帜则完全不同。如果我看到有人在他们的家外或生意场所悬挂那面旗帜，我可能根本不知道那个人相信什么。
We may not even like each other, but that flag, the decision to fly that flag, it feels like someone's telling me, you're in a place that's safe for black people. And you know, I think that was a big part of what Garvey wanted to say with the red black and green. Black folks in a world that is constantly threatening you, come together under this flag and feel safe. We talk about another interesting flag from our history, the Juneteenth flag.
我们甚至可能不喜欢对方，但那面旗帜，悬挂那面旗帜的决定，感觉就像有人在告诉我，“你处在一个对黑人安全的地方。”你知道，我认为这是加维想用红黑绿旗帜表达的重要部分。在一个不断威胁你的世界里的黑人，在这个旗帜下团结起来，感到安全。我们谈谈我们历史上另一面有趣的旗帜，六月节旗帜。
After this. Flag Day may be over, but there's another big day coming up later this week that involves its own flag, Juneteenth, which is a portmanteau of June and 19th. Juneteenth has other names too, including Freedom Day or Liberation Day. But by whatever title, the day is really important. It commemorates the emancipation of slaves in the United States, specifically the date when the end of slavery was enforced by the Union Army in Galveston, Texas on June 19th, 1865.
在这之后。旗帜日可能已经结束了，但本周晚些时候还有另一个重要的日子，涉及它自己的旗帜，六月节（Juneteenth），它是六月（June）和第十九日（19th）的合成词。六月节也有其他名字，包括自由日或解放日。但无论叫什么名字，这一天都非常重要。它纪念美国奴隶的解放，具体来说是1865年6月19日联邦军队在德克萨斯州加尔维斯顿强制执行奴隶制结束的日期。
The date has been celebrated in many places for over a century, and it seems to be on its way to becoming a national holiday. And as part of this push for recognition, the founder of the National Juneteenth Celebration Foundation, Ben Hath, designed a Juneteenth flag in 1997. It was then revised in 2000 by Lisa Jean Graff before it was officially flown. Now, this time of year, people ask me about the Juneteenth flag all the time, more and more every year, because it's a great flag, it's really lovely. Like the American flag, the Juneteenth
这个日期在许多地方已经被庆祝了一个多世纪，而且它似乎正在成为一个全国性的节日。作为推动认可的一部分，全国六月节庆祝基金会的创始人本·海斯在1997年设计了一面六月节旗帜。它后来在2000年由丽莎·简·格拉夫修改，然后才被正式悬挂。现在，每年的这个时候，人们总是问我关于六月节旗帜的问题，每年越来越多，因为它是一面很棒的旗帜，它真的很可爱。像美国国旗一样，六月节
flag is red, white, and blue, which is a more striking choice to me since all the stuff I learned from Christopher's reporting in this episode about the Pan-African red-black and green-flack. The Juneteenth flag features a central white star referencing the Lone Star State, where the last of the country's enslaved population finally learned of their freedom in 1865. Around that is another 12-pointed white star outline, and together they symbolize a star of Texas bursting with new freedom throughout the land over a new horizon. That horizon consists of a red arch meeting the blue sky above. To quote the creators of the flag, the red-white and blue colors communicate that the American slaves and their descendants were all Americans.
旗帜是红、白、蓝三色，这对我来说是一个更引人注目的选择，因为我从克里斯托弗在本期节目中关于泛非红、黑、绿旗帜的报道中学到了很多。六月节旗帜的中心是一颗白星，象征着“孤星之州”德克萨斯州，该国最后一批被奴役的人口最终于1865年在此获知了他们的自由。围绕着它的是另一个12角白星轮廓，它们共同象征着德克萨斯之星在新的地平线上向大地迸发出新的自由。地平线由一道红色的拱门与上方的蓝天相接而成。引用旗帜设计者的话说，红、白、蓝三色传达了美国奴隶及其后代都是美国人的信息。
Sometimes the flag is shown with the Juneteenth, date, June 19th, 1865 written across the fly end. Frankly, this is not my favorite edition, but the basic flag is top-torn. It's a good flag, as is the red, black, and green. So if you fly them together, get ready to talk about all the interesting history that we discussed in the show with the people who passed by. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Christopher Johnson edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, music by our director of Sound Sean Rial mixed by Amita Ganatra. Delaney Hall is the executive producer Kirk Colstad is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Joe Rosenberg,
有时旗帜上会写有六月节的日期，即1865年6月19日。坦率地说，这不是我最喜欢的版本，但基本款旗帜是一流的。这是一面很好的旗帜，红、黑、绿旗帜也是如此。所以如果你把它们挂在一起，准备好和路过的人谈谈我们在节目中讨论的所有有趣的历史。本周的《99% Invisible》由克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑，音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里亚尔创作，阿米塔·加纳特拉混音。德莱尼·霍尔是执行制片人，柯克·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，团队其他成员包括乔·罗森伯格，
Vivian Leigh, Chris Barouba, Katie Mingle, Washington, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family. Now it had quartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can Twitter me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and read it too.
薇薇安·利、克里斯·巴鲁巴、凯蒂·明格尔、华盛顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。现在它位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，或关注节目@99PI.org。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。
You can find other shows I love from Stitcher, as well as every past episode of this program at 99PI dot org. Still no word from the top brass. So here we go. SSS TTTTITITTCCCHHHEEEERRRRSTITURE Do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do We can park as if we want to. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目，以及本节目的每一期往期节目。高层还没有消息。所以我们开始吧。Stitcher。我们可以随心所欲地停车。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。